let me get started on
uh lecture 20. so i'm going to finish up
with what we discussed last time which
is lecture 1919 and i'm going to talk
about
lecture 20 which is about malleability
and inaccurate accessibility of
preferences
um for now we're going to talk a little
bit more about defaults
and frames and nudges in particular um
so what we left it off last time was um
we talked about default effects
we talked about that in particular in
retirement savings defaults can be
sort of setting essentially in one
default option
that is like what happens if you do
nothing
in a retirement savings account setting
a certain default option can have very
powerful effects in
affecting people's behavior in a domain
that's really important in this case
savings uh and in a domain where uh
traditional economic
tools have not really um gone very far
isn't like matching contributions or any
sort of like
types of like financial education etc
it's just not doing very much it's like
expensive to do and it's hard to change
behavior while using defaults is really
powerful and can
cause large behavior behavior change a
large sort of
changes in outcomes even like years
later let me talk a little bit about
like well what is the optimal default
decision regime
and that's uh uh getting into tricky um
territory
we talked about this um last time a
little bit um we'll talk about this
again in the last lecture on lecture 23
when we talk about
policy so when you think about like
active choice versus default so what is
active choice
active choice to remind you is like
somebody has asked at the beginning or
directly asked like you have to make a
choice and like um i'm just sort of
forcing you to do it
more or less and sort of the company
hires somebody and in the hiring package
there's just a form that you need to
fill out and otherwise you cannot really
start the
company some sense that's not really
enforceable but effectively essentially
just everybody makes
some choice that's essentially active
choice versus default which is just like
if you do nothing you either get like
zero retirement savings or some positive
amounts
now um if people are really different
then essentially active choice is a
great thing because if people really
have different preferences then we
shouldn't just push them into one
direction or the other they should sort
of choose everybody's shoes on their own
what's best for them
in contrast if you think most people are
the same anyway
and in addition people don't really know
what's best for them well then it might
be better to just
provide one default within most people
that's best for most people but then
most people will stick to any way
because
these defaults tend to stick and if
people don't know what they
want or what's good for them then sort
of letting them choose actively might
make things potentially
um worse anyway right and so
uh that's sort of the fundamental
trade-off when people have you know come
down in different sides of this and it
depends on your view kind of about
sophistication and so on of customers or
of people now one
big and important issue with like
defaults and with the nudges
um in general which i'm going to talk
about to you in a second
is we kind of want to make sure that we
don't make people
worse off in some ways by pushing people
in certain directions for example one
thing you might say is well
not why not set the default to like five
percent or ten percent of retirement
savings
well then you you worry about people
potentially over saving in the
retirement savings accounts
and then essentially they have lots of
credit card debt potentially which might
be even larger
like you know that sorry the the
interest rate on the credit card debt
might be really large and people get in
trouble
or people then would draw premature
aliens on which is also to potentially
um worse for them we talked very briefly
about the
smart plan which again i'm going to get
back to in lecture 23 um as well
now
now um i also talked briefly about sort
of uh
default effects also are quite powerful
in other settings for example in organ
donations in some places
um organ donations are explicit consent
which is like you have to
opt in and otherwise you will not be an
organ donor in other countries and this
is from a while ago
um in other countries things are
different where there is what's called
presumed consent which is like you have
to opt out and otherwise if you do not
opt out
you presume to consenting to organ um
translation you see essentially huge
differences
in otherwise quite similar um uh
countries which sort of shows you that
the default here can have really um
large effects
there's some other examples of default
effects in particular when it comes to
like voter registration or
green energy choices in some cases in
particular when it comes to voter
registration it's actually quite hard to
come with arguments
against setting the default in a certain
way like in some sense like
getting voters to be registered when you
get like so
say like a driver's license or the like
it seems just like very straightforward
and like or
you know over the turn 18 that seems
like a very straightforward thing to do
and sort of um there in some ways um the
defaults can really sort of remove some
barriers
um uh and inefficiencies where like you
know
we think we should agree that like most
or we should everybody should be able to
vote if they would like to
uh uh with some exceptions perhaps
and so uh if you can default people into
getting registered to vote that seems
like a good thing ambiguously so those
sort of default effects can be really
really um
powerful now uh uh let's talk
a little bit about nudges again we're
gonna talk about this again in lecture
23 when it comes about policy but let me
sort of define the issue and sort of be
clear about that
uh so you might have sort of come across
a very famous book by
richard taylor who recently won the
nobel prize in economics and cass
sunstein uh called nudge
i'll give you the definition by um uh
castenstein
who says a nudge is a feature of the
social environment that affects
people's choices without imposing
coercion of any kind of a material or
any kind of material incentive
so that's default to sort of like a
clear case of that where essentially you
just say okay
if you don't do anything i'm gonna just
pick a choice for you
um but you can choose however uh in
whichever way you want and sort of there
there's essentially no material
incentive but i'm changing essentially
your
choice environment or what people would
call sometimes the choice architecture
and there's other versions of that
there's simplification
information disclosure again these are
all things that are like usually
available people can figure it out on
their own but make it sort of easier for
for people and one of the big mantras of
any ass like
uh they tell her about like you know
what are you right right what's the main
thing we should do
to improve people's behavior um they
failed it off and say make it easy for
people essentially people are
um often um and he says that about
himself people are lazy
and you know they make simple choices
and like if you make it easy for them to
make the right choice they will be more
likely to make
good choices for them there's some other
things like warnings reminders uh notice
for reminders for example again like you
already have the information that
somebody gave it to you previously
so really it's only like if you have
memory issues um uh you might be
uh that might be useful for you there's
no
material incentives or the like uses of
social norms that would be things like
you know i'm telling you like all of
your
um friends did x now would you like to
do x or y
or you know i can send you letters and
say um your neighbors use
so much energy and you use more energy
than your neighbor
and then i put like a sad face next to
it or something and then you know
you might feel bad about it because of
social norms
and sort of reduce your energy um usage
which
people have in fact um done uh you can
also like increase ease and convenience
this is exactly what like
um power decrease is inconvenience
that's exactly what the accelerator
would say
those are things like for example uh you
know you can put like
snicker bars next to um the the the
counter at the cashier
or i can put like sort of like apples
next to it and you know
people are more likely to buy apples
when it's easy or simple
when they're reminded of eating apples
and they're more likely to eat
snickerdoodle as far as if they
uh essentially if they're salient to
them to the extent that they want make
people to make
uh certain what one might think of like
as good choices
making it easy for them to make the good
choice without sort of restricting
anybody's
um choice sets or coveraging them in any
way
is considered a nudge and then there's
also some things about framing of
choices
as in like gains versus losses in terms
of their
contract any questions on this
okay so then let me give you briefly
sort of and again we're going to get
back to all of this in lecture 23 but
let me briefly sort of give you a couple
of examples of nudges in some cases
where like it's pretty clear that
um some matches are a good idea so one
thing and
that we talked about quite a bit already
when it comes to like procrastination or
self-control
um uh self-control problems so present
bias or
present focus is uh the health domain
and what people
um in particular individuals and society
often have aligned goals
where like you know individuals often
want behavioral change they want to
improve their diets increase physical
activity stop smoking get vaccinated and
use less energy and so on
and often there are societal costs of
these behaviors a lack of those
behaviors
sometimes there's actualities from like
smoking or um
getting uh or not getting vaccinated
sometimes there's just
like health care costs in the leg from
like obesity and so on where like you
know um
it's bad for everybody if the population
is
sick now so these goals are now aligned
and the social planner might want people
to
improve their diet or the government
might want that uh i might want to like
do smoking and so on um but you know
individuals as we
saw previously often failed to follow um
through and sort of
often education and information
interventions are often ineffective
um even price interventions are often
ineffective or in sense of like you know
increasing prices so incentivizing
people doesn't always work plus it's
quite expensive to do
so one natural question you might want
to ask is well can we use some nudges
to align intentions and actions and the
reason why this is really popular in
particular among
governments is that it's really cheap to
do this right so essentially
sending some reminders or like the like
or providing information in one way or
the other
is essentially free and if governments
don't have um
a lot of money that's an easy thing to
do as opposed to like paying people
which is you know
quite expensive um in many cases uh so
here's an example of like a free
intervention which is about
flu shot communication this is a study
by katy milkman and co-authors from
2011.
so here uh uh the the goal of the
intervention is to get people to sign up
or to actually get
um flu shots so the control group got
like an informational mailing
i'll show you this in a second a
treatment group got um the same plus
like um
and encouraged men to make a date um
plan and the treatment group got
like the same plus um make a date plan
and a time plot let me show you what
this looks like
so here's the control condition this is
just an informational mailing
uh you know saying like here the company
is and this is a company trying to do
this
is holding a free uh flu shot clinic
and companies very much want their
workers to get flu shots because you
know that
reduces essentially sort of uh sick days
if everybody gets their flu shot
not only are they healthier and it's
probably good for them and they're like
less at risk of
you know dying and infecting each other
or just being sick
but it's also good for the company
because the company now um uh
gets workers to actually show up more
and have like fewer um
sick days so here's sort of the control
condition it looks like a perfectly
reasonable
um uh letter where you say here is
like these these days in which you can
sort of like sign up and you are
informed about like the dates and times
of the workplace flu
clinic now the um treatment condition is
the date plan condition which
essentially
is asking people to um
or invite people to choose a concrete
date for getting a fluvax
uh vaccine and the rest of the the
information mailer is exactly the same
so essentially that's just asking people
like
you know pick a day of the week and a
month
um a month and a day on a day of week
and just
write it down presumably that also then
encourages people to put it into that
calendar
um uh the like and sort of act to some
form of a reminder
notice there's no incentive here there's
no financial incentives there's no
conversion and so on it's just saying
like why don't you just pick a day right
now
uh just have a look check your calendar
and just figure out you know make a plan
for this
and um the second condition is then make
a date and a time
um um planned condition which is to say
why don't you also pick a time
um which is like even more concrete that
would be you know uh monday uh october
26th
at like 9 a.m or wherever i'm going to
go presumably that also encourages
people to put it into their um
calendar now um what you then get in
this experiment in this very simple
experiment uh you get to like when you
just send a letter 33
actually get the flu shot when you also
send a date plan 34 and when you send a
date plan at a time plan it's 37
now these effects are a little bit
underwhelming in the sense they're kind
of small you know it's like uh
you know 1.6 percentage points and 4.2
percentage points and then relative
terms that's you know not not huge
effects
but notice um what's beautiful about
here is that the costs are
essentially zero right so in some sense
if you value additional flu
um short adherence if you value more
people um
getting flu shots then you know a 4.2 um
percentage parts increase which is about
like a 10 percent or like
whatever 11 12 or something increase
relative to the control group
that's quite a bit of uh of an increase
for something that's essentially
free so the cost effectiveness of this
is of course very very high because you
know it's
essentially free and we cost somebody um
like a few minutes to sort of write this
down
um or like designed as the sheet
but really at its cost exactly the same
to send like the
uh sheet share on the left versus the
sheet here on the right
so that's kind of like an example of
like a win-win kind of situation where
like
um we make things essentially more
effective
it's not really hurting anybody and it's
cheap and free to do
and sort of everybody is happy and it's
sort of uncontroversial in the sense of
like
nobody would argue that this is a bad
thing of course some people might sort
of
have some concerns about the flu shots
themselves which i don't think there's
any actual evidence
against that as far as i know but that's
sort of an example where you say look
this is very cheap to do
so presumably you should sort of pick
the right
uh mailing or the right design if a
mailing to encourage people to do
desirable things
at least from the company's perspective
while also preserving
people's freedom not spending any money
but also not encouraging
anybody any questions on this
okay so here's another example of a
similar intervention which is um
uh uh signing up for fafsa this is a
paper about bettinger adolf in 2009
uh where essentially um
people were provided free uh additional
assistance in completing and filing
applications for
um college financial aid this is fafsa
the financial aid for
for college um and it really uh
increased um uh college enrollment uh
not only fafsa completion but also
college enrollment
and um they're sort of different
conditions one is control versus just
providing people information only here's
an information of like you could get
some
fafsa help and so on but it seems to be
really what you need is like
um some additional assistance of
of of completing and filing this
application just somebody essentially
walking you through the file
the the filing um um has a huge
impact there's a bit of a question of
like is that really just a nudge or is
it like a more powerful intervention but
it's a really minor intervention where
some people just need some a little help
in
in filling out this form and it has
pretty large effects if you look at sort
of the fafsa completion of like
completion of these forms
and actually reasonably large effect on
like college enrollment
you might think this is a hugely
important choice and sort of if you get
people to
make that really big change
that's pretty remarkable um for doing
some very simple things where i'm just
saying
help me complete and fill out like a
simple um form
something that you could have done um
anyway so
and here again so that this is a
relatively cheap thing to do
and it's it's essentially equivalent to
the impact of several thousands of
dollars of
education subsidy so if you wanted to
essentially pay people to
uh go to college subsidize that which
you might want to do for
for for other reasons anyway one key
issue with that is that
not only um is it perhaps not
particularly effective
but also you're going to pay a lot of
informational people you're going to pay
a lot of people who would have gone to
college anyway you're going to pay the
subsidy
so if you have a low budget that's
really um uh
tough to do and sort of then there's not
a lot of
um the cost effectiveness tends to be
very low because you
you have essentially a low impact but
like really high
costs and you can read about this more
in the link that i had
but essentially the bottom line here is
again like you can do very small
changes that can have pretty large um
effects there's other types of examples
that government use or where governments
use
nudges another example would be sending
out letters for people to
pay their taxes which essentially are
like reminders or often like appealing
to people's um
sort of pro-sociality and various ways
but like the government sends you lottos
and there's different ways in which you
can get these write this letters you
could say you should pay your taxes or
everybody is paying their taxes or good
citizens pay their taxes and so on
and people there's a whole industry of
like nudge units where people have then
try to figure out what's the best
way of doing that and uh by doing that
in different ways that can have pretty
large effects
on people's um behaviors
and the government sort of love this
because you know it's a very cheap thing
to do and they can have large impacts
and change behaviors but quite a bit in
this case in the tax case
increase revenue by quite a bit um
without costing the government very much
because often they'll
send some letters anyway and there's
then some more and some
less effective ways of doing that when
you think about the
the intervention that i have here on the
slide the fafsa one is essentially just
the effects almost surely will be
persistent in the sense that like this
is a one judge
one shot choice whether like you send
your kid to college or not
and once you increase the college
enrollment which you know
um might have some other issues but once
you do that
uh uh there's gonna be persistent
effects because once kids go to college
they know that has effects on their
behaviors and so on now what you're
saying something else which is some
other decisions we're just like about
paying taxes we're like every year you
get this letter from the government that
sort of tells you you should pay your
taxes maybe the first time it works
maybe the second time as well but at
some point you're like whatever
um i don't care that's a great question
and i don't know whether we have lots of
evidence on that
i think the governments would sort of
and uh i think there's some research on
this that i just i'm not
sure i'm aware of um i think governments
or people would say well
in some sense we don't care that much
about it uh
i says of course we care but it doesn't
change the fact that like in the first
year
so we know that the first year works
pretty well and there's some things that
work better than others
many governments send some letters or
some forms of mailers
anyway so what you want to do is kind of
like make sure you optimize
at least the first or second time you
contact people
and that might have some persistent
effects by themselves even if you don't
recontact
them because once you start paying your
taxes maybe then it becomes a habit and
people do it anyway
but even if that's not persistent
governments would say well if that gets
people to pay taxes
more at least once or twice that's worth
sort of the money spent
that you have like there's just some you
need like somebody essentially needs to
design this letters there's like
templates of what you can use
and um uh
uh that's that's actually very cheap to
do
and uh uh has pretty large effects at
least in the short run
i think they're saying something correct
which is sometimes it's like
some effects on like it's just
information versus like some things
about making you feel bad or social
norms
i think the information things if people
if you think people just forget stuff
for example if people forget to get
their flu shot and so on you should
probably send reminders and so on and
get them to do that
if people if there's sort of these
social norms or sort of
our governments you feel bad in some
ways maybe those things are maybe more
likely to potentially at least
uh go away once you do it like 17 times
because at some point people
yeah whatever like the same letter i got
always and i haven't paid my taxes last
time i'm not going to pay them now
either it's um it's additional assist
assistance in completing and filing
applications right so essentially it's
not so the financial aid is always
available it's just who takes advantage
of financial aid
depends on how easy you make it to
people and whether you support some
provide some support in completing and
filing applications
there's also something with that where
essentially uh once you do your taxes
essentially it already pre-fills you the
forms which is even easier
to do but essentially this falls under
the category of making things
easy for people and uh that can sort of
change behaviors
um quite a bit but the the key part in
the
nudges and this is let me get back again
to the definition
is that uh there's no financial
um incentives right so this is the key
part here is
without imposing any coercion or without
uh paying any kind of material
incentives or at least only very very
small incentives there's a bit of a
question how to define that
but once i pay you a thousand dollars to
go to college or whatever subsidize you
that's not a notch anymore or once i'm
like taking away certain options from
you and just sort of like eliminating
choices from your choice set
again that's not a nudge that's
something else that's changing your
choices this one is
nudges are explicitly about keeping
people's choices
um uh fully free and available
but making it easier for them
to make a certain choice presumably a
choice that's desired in some ways by
the social planner or about people's
uh plans for their future so anyway
there's a large
um sort of set of examples
of different nudges and so on and they
can be fairly effective um of course not
for everybody and often the fraction of
people who are
swayed by these matches is not huge in
part because if you think about it like
essentially people need to be sort of
like marginal in some ways
if people just really really don't want
to go to college because it's too
expensive for them or whatever for
other reasons or if people really want
to go to college anyway
the nudge will not change that behavior
whether somebody fills out the form or
not doesn't really matter
but if somebody is sort of like ah maybe
i should send the kid to college or not
but nowadays it's like form and then
they forget about it and so on and so
forth
for that kind of people there will be
like potentially uh large effects
um but sort of then by definition in
some ways the fraction of people who are
actually marginal will not be huge
but again since the costs tend to be
extremely low
it tends to be very much like cost
effective to do so
now again sort of um previewing a little
bit what comes in the policy lecture is
so minor interventions can have large
effects
but you know nudges can often achieve
sort of uh
so in some cases that just can achieve
unambiguous improvements like if you
send people reminders and they forget to
get the
flu shot and now they do the flu shot or
if they certain
you know if people don't take that
medication and you remind them or
provide information
or some other forms where you get help
people to to take their medication
it's pretty clear that that's making
people better off
but there's also a bunch of challenges
and other situations which is kind of
like
uh in some cases it's not at all obvious
like which nudge to choose
i'll be making everybody like better off
and people some people made worse off
for example should everybody say for
retirement are we pushing people to save
for too much
take too much should everybody go to
college maybe in some ways for some
people it's more suitable than for
others to go to college often it's a
huge financial expense for the family
and you know if then the job prospects
are not necessarily better
compared to not going to college and
it's not clear that one should do that
there's also some evidence or some
concerns about not just making you feel
people feel bad so like you get these
letters that says you're like
destroying the environment and like you
know with all these like sad faces how
many worse than your neighbors
people might just feel bad about it and
you know um uh
you should put some uh you put some
weight on that if you sort of
if they send these letters to like lots
of house a thousand households and like
50 households or 20 households change
their behavior in certain ways
but 300 households feel bad about it
because you just like feel uncomfortable
getting these nudges or like you get all
these like phone calls or
spams on or they feel bad about the
environment from like
sending too many letters um we should
put some weight on that and there's like
then there's some trade-offs it's not
like entirely free and then you know
there's some costs and benefits of that
there's also some questions about which
self should we respect we talked about
this a lot before which is you know
if oneself wants to be very virtuous and
exercise a lot and so on and the other
one wants to sit on the couch and watch
tv
or if oneself wants to smoke and the
other one does not
it's not obvious that we should respect
the long
short-run self that wants to just enjoy
themselves and so on and sort of now
there's tricky issues and like i'll be
actually making people better off
um or not and we'll get back to these
issues in the last lecture which talks
about
policy any questions on
this lecture
okay this is actually lecture 20 about
malleability and accessibility of
preferences
um this is a in a way a more radical
deviation from neoclassical economics
because so far we have always said
people know their preferences
people have certain beliefs their
beliefs might be wrong and so on
but crucially um people knew what they
were doing and they were deliberately
making certain choices
and uh whether you know their their
preferences were perhaps uh including
present bias so social preferences the
reference dependence the like
but these preferences were given and
fixed and people knew what those
preferences are
now we're going to deviate from that and
think about it and i'll show you some
evidence that people might not actually
um aid um these preferences might be
malleable
and b people might not even like
understand why they want what they want
and sort of um the preference is
sort of quite mysterious to people and
it's quite
easy in some ways to manipulate people
in some ways uh without them even
like understanding and knowing about it
so i'll tell you some uh about some very
fascinating
um psychology work which is called the
paper is called telling more than you
can know from nisbet and wilson which is
a classic paper and social psychology
um and then we're going to talk a little
bit about willingness to pay and then
the paper by
um a reality coherent arbitrariness
which um
you were supposed to read for um today
okay so um let's go step back a little
bit and talk about the nisbet and wilson
um
uh uh paper so this is um so many uh
questions you might have any questions
about you know
cognitive processes underlying our
choices evaluations
judgments and behaviors you want to
wonder why do you like a certain person
versus not what do you like about them
and why do you like this person and not
another person
and why are you friends with this person
versus somebody else and why do you like
math versus english and so on and so
forth
um how did you solve a certain problem
once you sort of asked to solve some
problems how did you come up with the
solution
uh you know why did you take this job or
why did you take this class was this
another class
and you might sort of say well i like
this one and not that one and i really
like sort of like computer
science versus like math versus
economics um
but you know when i then when you then
ask about yourself for others you know
why exactly do you like that one versus
something else
you'll realize quickly that people often
um
don't quite have a good answer um to
those questions and this but in wilson's
sort of fairly
um provocative paper says essentially we
have no idea where these preferences are
coming from
and we're just making stuff up and so
let me give you some examples of that
the first example is what what's called
meyer's um
two-string problem from 1931. this is
like a very simple one of these classic
psychology experiments
the experiments works as follows there's
um two cords um hung from the ceiling
of a lab with many objects such as poles
ring stands clamps pliers and extension
cords
subjects are now asked are told that the
task is to tie the two ends of the ports
together so there's two chords hanging
um on the side of like of each side of
the room
and subjects are supposed to like tie
these two chords together
the problem is that the chords are
placed far apart from each other such
that
subjects can't while holding onto one
chord reach the other so you can't just
take one chord and then sort of like try
to reach the other because it's too far
um away and so um
and then there's all these like
different objects in the room and
somebody's just sort of trying to figure
out how to do this
and so then they usually sort of they
they're told so usually they come up
with one or two solutions that are not
really solutions because it doesn't
really work
so they can get the users like extension
cord they use the pliers and so on and
the clamp and some ring
whatever and it just doesn't work and
um and then they sort of try it and keep
keep trying but it doesn't really um
work out and then they're told to do it
um another way
and then meyer the experimenter walks
into the room
at some point or walks around and
essentially accidentally this is sort of
like on purpose of course
accidentally puts some of the cords in
motion and
subjects then very quickly afterwards
figure out the solution within the next
45
seconds of course the reason here is why
they figure it out is because now that
chords are put into motion and subjects
sort of figure out then
how to do this and what you're supposed
to do is essentially put the chords in
motion and once you put them in motion
you can essentially reach them both and
then put
it um together um i have a video here a
little traumatized from last time um
where it didn't work out so i'm not sure
no i don't even see it so maybe let's
just skip it but you can watch the video
of that it's the first sort of two and a
half minutes this video i don't
know we don't see anything but there's a
video that sort of demonstrates
um this task um that you can want to
just skip this
so now then afterwards people are asked
well how did you come up
um uh with the idea of using a pendulum
and sort of people then have all these
like explanations well it just dawned on
me
i was the only i was the only thing left
i thought about all these different
things and at the end i came up with
this other solution which is like using
these strings as a pendulum
or you know i just realized the chord
with what's swinging how fast and the
weight on it so
like what the solution at the end is
like you put the plier in one of the
chords and then swing it and then you
sort of use the other one and then you
can put them together
there's one harvard psychology faculty
subject in fact had the following
explanation which is
having exhausted everything else the
next thing was to swing it
i thought of the situation of swinging
across a river i had an imagery of
monkeys swinging
from trees this imagery uh appeared
simultaneously with a solution
the idea appeared complete now of course
the problem here is that
um the the the problem here is
that's all like [ __ ] because um uh
the reason why people come up with a
solution
is because um as i told you um meyer was
walking in and accidentally putting the
chords in motion
and you know you can sort of there's
differences in timing sometimes they
would come in earlier sometimes later
and every time you know that
experimenter walks in people would sort
of accidentally then figure it out
and then come up with these like
elaborate explanations
and the reason why we know that this is
because um uh
the experimenter coming in is because if
the experiment doesn't accidentally come
in and puts the the chords in motion
then essentially people are not figuring
out so we know the causal the true
causal effect here is
the experimenter coming in and
suggesting a solution to people
but people then make up all these
stories where um uh
uh including like the monkeys swing from
trees how they came up with a solution
which is clearly not how they came up
with the solution
the reason why they came up with the
solution is because meyer touched the
the strings okay now there's a second
example here which or there's three
examples in total so let me tell you
about example
number or let me ask first any questions
about this um
study by the way you should um
lower your hands uh if you asked stuff
previously like brian and carmen
and yes you have additional questions
okay so let me um let me tell you um
uh the second study now this is a study
by
um uh uh uh latin and darley um which is
uh we talked
i talked to i tell you this a little bit
about which is the um these are
the impacts of bystanders and witnesses
on helping behaviors
i told you about the story of the good
samaritan before this is sort of a
similar um
study and this is essentially um a
situation that's again created by social
psychologists
it's not a real situation but people are
meant to think that it's real
and so here um the more people over here
someone in another room having what
sounds like an
epileptic seizure the lower the
probability that any given individual
will rush to help
and uh you get similar results for
individuals reaction to dangerous
looking smoke coming out of the ceiling
of a room so like there's people in an
experiment and they
have like smoke coming out in a room and
the more people that are there
the less likely is any given person
perhaps because their free writing is to
actually do something about it and you
know this looks kind of very dangerous
but nobody does anything because
essentially other people are also not
doing anything
now when you then ask people afterwards
you know um
uh what influenced your choices and
um essentially um when you ask them like
directly and tactfully and bluntly
um you always get the same answer that
essentially they think their behavior
had not been influenced by
the other people present they think like
for whatever reason they didn't do
anything and
maybe they thought it wasn't so bad or
like it wasn't really danger or whatever
but of course these are randomized
experiments we know that some subjects
were influenced by the presence of other
people because precisely the experiment
was creating the aberration and it
affected
people's behavior yet when you ask
people people essentially just don't
understand that and sort of
um then come up with other explanations
of
why they do or did what they um in fact
did
and uh number three is sort of very
similar these are
um uh called sort of erroneous reports
about position effects
these are studies where um uh uh
certain items were positioned in
different ways
um to get people to uh when people were
evaluating them
so there um uh passer buys were asked to
evaluate some clothing um
and they're asking about people's the
quality and the preferences
um or their the quality of certain goods
and people's preferences between
different goods
and the way this experiment was set up
and this is sort of essentially like a
marketing experiment if you want
essentially there's a pronounced left to
right position effect
the rightmost object was heavily
overchosen in these experiments and
that's in some sense irrelevant why
that's the case
but essentially from previous
experiments we know that essentially the
rightmost
object is most uh likely to be chosen
perhaps because people look at it first
so because
they look at it last and so on it
doesn't matter what's important for our
purposes is that
the rightmost object is most happily
chosen people like that object the best
in these experiments
and then you know there's gonna be
randomization and the positioning of
experiments
and people then ask well why did you
choose this sweater versus
another and no ob subject whatsoever
ever mentions the position of the
article and the uh
in the room and virtually all subjects
denied it was when asked directly about
the
possible effect of the position of the
article and people come up with all
these explanations it's like
of green is really always my five
favorite color and like the sweater is
really fluffy and this and that and like
you know i really um
i like it for reason x and y of course
that's true for some people
but we know that at least some people
must be swayed by these position effects
because we set up an experiment
to precisely do that and then that
essentially swayed behavior in a very
predictable
way so essentially there are these
determinants on people's
preferences behavior that people do not
seem to understand okay so let me sort
of just summarize what did we learn
um so there are many instances in which
subjects have no idea why they choose um
what they choose
and then people and this is you can read
this more in this paper um which i think
is a beautiful um
paper people appear to make up stories
that are based on their um
a priori implicit causal theories what i
mean by that essentially
they have some theory of like why they
do certain things
and when you ask them then okay well why
did you do what you just did
people would sort of come up with some
ways of justifying exposed in some ways
uh uh their behavior based on some
theories that they had about themselves
and sort of you know i always like
fluffy sweaters and therefore you choose
the sweater of course it happens to be
the only choose a sweater
if it's only very much on the right
versus on the left but people then sort
of
have their ways in which they then
explain what they do um
based on essentially things that they
sort of essentially um
make up any questions on this
before move on
and i encourage you to read the paper uh
um
more for fun than for anything uh it
makes you kind of wonder quite a lot and
why you do what you do
and why you prefer certain things versus
others
okay so let's briefly talk about two
experimental design tools which will be
useful
for the um coherent arbitrariness paper
one is what's called the strategy method
which you already came across a little
bit and the second one is what's called
the bdm
the back of the growth moisture
procedure procedure for eliciting values
i'll try to be um quick so
um we're often interested in and
behavior in
um rare um contingencies so
often we sort of ask the question how
would people behave in many different
contingencies some of them are often
quite rare that doesn't actually
don't happen very often and why do we
care about such contingencies well
sometimes we just care about them like
um per se and like it's inherently
important how people
um behave or like prevent certain
contingencies disasters earthquake
crowds etc
we care a lot about these things even if
they're sort of rarely happenings we
kind of want to know how people behave
in certain situations
but events and rare contingencies also
can affect uh on top of that
events and likely contingencies here's a
simple example if your roommates
um i think you'll punch them in the face
if they borrow your stuff without asking
them they will not
do it of course uh hopefully you are not
punching your roommates and uh
i very much do not want to encourage you
to do so but
um uh here the the key part here is that
punching is rare but important
um precisely because you might do so
in case they misbehave um they will not
borrow your stuff or steal your stuff
in the first place so essentially sort
of these offer equilibrium or rare uh
contingencies
might be quite important not because we
think they actually happen very often
but they sort of
discipline behavior um in other cases
now what's not a strategy method well
the strategy method
um helps you to
elicit behavior in many potentially rare
circumstances
by asking subjects what they would do
with the choice implemented if the
circumstances
arises that is to say i'm asking you for
different many different cases i'm going
to just
implement one of those cases and um
that's going to allow me to be an
incentive compatible in various ways
so since the decision does
count if the contingency occurs subjects
have an incentive to choose correctly
for each contingency
that is to say i could say you know
suppose um uh
this this is what we're doing in class
in some sense um
i talked about social preferences i said
you know i'm asking you to make a choice
i'm going to only pick one of you um to
implement that choice
and you have the incentives now um
to choose um or to answer truthfully
because it could always be the case that
your choice will be um implemented
and so that allows them the experiment
or me and that case to generate a lot of
data from one simple experiment
um where essentially you can give a
subject many different decisions
and then say only one of your choices
will actually be implemented for sure or
you can ask many people the same
question and say i'm
not going to do a lottery only one of
you or one of your choices will be
implemented
and so then that's essentially um
incentive compatible because it can
always be that your choice is the one or
one of the choices the one
that counts and when you look at sort of
experimental evidence
um it seems to suggest that the strategy
methods are asking like essentially
if i can ask you so there's experiments
where i can ask you a hundred different
questions and only one of them will be
implemented
versus a different group would be ask a
randomized group would be asked
only one question it turns out that
people actually answer and experiments
these questions pretty similarly
in both of these cases so that's to say
the strategy method seems to elicit
individuals
um through preferences pretty well
um sorry this is a little bit messed up
but i think that's fine so what's not a
becca declared martial procedure it's
essentially
a version of that which looks um
something like this
which is um uh people are asked
elicited so what the goal here is to
understand people's willingness to pay
for good
so subjects are told that a price for
the good will be randomly selected and
the price goes from like 50 cents to
let's say 10
and for each of these prices the person
is asked do you prefer
buy versus non not buy in these options
and so then you know i ask you to fill
out the entire form
tell me for each of these prices what
you want to do if the price is three
dollars what do you want if the price is
one dollar what you want if the price is
ten dollar what do you want
and then i'm going to afterwards then um
pick a price and say okay now the price
is 3.50
and now i'm going to just look at like
what did you actually say and whatever
your choice was then for that specific
price
um is going to be
implemented isn't that clear
now it doesn't really clear what the
problem is that we're trying to
uh uh uh overcome here suppose i'm
trying to sell you
a mug um and say or you know suppose i
have this this mug here i'm saying like
would you like to buy this mug it's a
very beautiful night with lots of trees
on them
i'd like to sell it to you and i'm
eliciting your willingness to pay
what's the problem that's that arises
from just asking you this directly
without the bdm procedure
what problem what is the bdm procedure
sort of helping with
right so if you go to a marketplace or
try to bargain with me on this like
mom which again is a a beautiful mug um
uh you might sort of want to shade your
valuation you might want to say
you might be willing to pay five dollars
but you're gonna save two dollars
because you are hoping to get a bargain
and get one of a cheap uh price for me
right and the key part here is that you
are essentially hoping that
your willingness to pay whatever you are
um
offering me will essentially change
whatever price
i'm offering the mug to you notice that
that's not the case here in the vm
procedure and the bdm procedure
uh whatever you say is independent of
the actual price that's implemented
right i'm saying essentially i'm going
to randomly pick one of those 10 or 20
prices here
and you're going to tell me for each of
those prices what you want either buy or
not buy
and your choices are since i'm
randomizing afterwards like which
price i'm actually going to pick your
choices are
irrelevant um for
which of the actual uh prices are uh
is selected and so now essentially get
around this issue about people shading
or essentially under reporting their
willingness to pay
precisely that's what makes it incentive
compatible and that's essentially what's
called the bdm mechanism
that's what many economists use in many
many experiments
experiments there's another version of
what's called the bdm which is
um uh a more straightforward
version of it here you know notice here
you have to ask 20 question asks would
you like to pay
would you like to buy it for 50 cents
1.50 two dollars and so on and so forth
um another version of this is um
uh i'm asking you straight up what's
your willingness to pay
and the bid is then compared to like a
price determined by a random
number generator i'm just saying like
tell me what your willingness to pay is
then i'm gonna do like a random number
uh generator if the subject's bid is
greater than the price
that's generated by the run number uh
generator
he or she pays the price not the
announced one has to pay
and receive the item being auctioned if
the subject spend is lower than the
price he or she pays nothing and
receives
nothing and so now here again
the final price the person must pay is
independent of what the person indicated
as your willingness to pay
which essentially solves the incentive
compatibility issue
think of like this version that i have
on this slide it's just a more efficient
way of eliciting uh the question that's
on the previous slide
this is essentially exactly the same
thing except for that it's a more
efficient thing to do
the problem with this version often is
like comprehension people get confused
so people tend to still
try to bargain and give like lower
willingness to pay so
sometimes this version works better
because it's much easier much
transparent but you say here's a price
do you want to buy it or not versus
uh and so on well here it's people are
sort of
tend to because they used to essentially
bargain they tend to sort of under
report at least
um sometimes any questions on this
so now i'm also going to skip this
video it's like a fun video who knows
the story of tom sawyer and the fans
i think it's in the readings no
i'm sorry it was misbehaving he was
essentially punished to um
paint the fence he really didn't want to
do it but then his friend comes along
and essentially he sort of tricks his
friend into thinking this is really like
such a fun task
and it ends up being essentially the
friend even paying him
for um painting the fence um and he not
having to
to do it and the point of the story of
course is that um
uh people's willingness to pay is
malleable in the sense
like even to the extent that like people
don't even know whether they're willing
to pay for something or you have to pay
them something um
to do it and so essentially people's
preferences are inherently malleable by
the way they're being marketed or the
way they appear to them are being sold
to them
and you can watch the video and the in
the slides if you download it
for whatever reason this is not working
on uh zoom at least for now
so um stepping back a little bit so
overall um so far we talked about two
key components of individual decision
making
utility functions what people want and
what they care about and beliefs how
people
perceive themselves and patterns in the
world and so
understanding these of course is
important because you know that
determines people's choices
now so far we have always sort of
pretended and said you know people's
preferences beliefs are always sharply
or people are always sharply aware of
what they want and believe
and constantly make plans in this for
example
homeowner might have reference dependent
preferences but they know what their
preferences are
um you know there might be some issues
about how the reference point is
determined
but the preference is the function the
functional form is always like fixed and
it's known
a person might have the wrong theory of
the world but she always has some
beliefs in mind what she uses to make
those choices
or smoker might act suboptimally but he
always has this fully specific strategy
in mind for all his current and future
decisions right so people
the smoker might sort of have some
issues with present bias or some wrong
beliefs in some ways on the other
but the utility function was always
assumed to be fixed
and no okay now we're going to deviate
from that
if you think about it like um what are
your preferences and like what you like
and what you're not like
in many cases um we actually don't know
and uh in many cases people sort of just
uh make things
up as they go along so um that's to say
like people are just essentially making
some choices
um and this is what were the examples
that i showed you from earlier the three
example that you
showed you first where people are just
induced to make certain choices one way
or the other
depending on their choice environment
depending on their social influence and
tom sawyer's case what he tells tells
his friend his friend is not willing to
pay
to pay defense which actually is a
punishment so people's preferences seem
inherently
um malleable and so that's
um uh what this paper um about queer and
arbitrariness is very much um
about and so if you think about it um
in some ways um almost all of
um economics in any class that you have
taken
uh the professor or any sort of in any
book
people will write down utility function
as if that's some truth that we know
about the world and this is what the
utility function looks like
but if you think about it in many cases
actually we don't know what is due
utility functioning
if somebody asks you about particular
about new goods um
who knows what our preferences actually
are so for example if you say you look
at some
you're trying to buy a monitor and
there's like a 30 inch monitor versus a
24 inch monitor
who knows how much you're willing to pay
for that like you know maybe maybe 50
maybe 100 maybe 20 maybe nothing it's
very hard to sort of figure this
um out and sort of when make when asked
to make these kinds of decisions
people tend to sort of construct their
preferences on the stuff they
essentially make stuff
up and so um
because of that because people are sort
of fundamentally in some ways unsure
about their preferences
this construction of their valuation
is very much easily manipulated by often
uh cues that should be really um
irrelevant
and so one example that i showed you a
little bit um uh
in the i think in the second class uh or
from the survey
is what's called anchoring this is also
in the aurelia paper
which essentially is what they were
doing is they were um uh
asking people about uh
uh their willingness to pay their social
security number and then afterwards
their willingness to pay for different
things
about like um wine design books
chocolates and so on
notice that these are somewhat unusual
things that people wouldn't necessarily
buy every day
and essentially what you see is people
who are in the highest quantile of the
social security number
which is like your number um five have
much higher willingness to pay and this
is also all incentive compatible sort of
elicitation methods essentially
using some form of pdf methods um
people's willingness to pay his way
higher
um when their social security number uh
the last digits of their social
security number are higher now of course
that shouldn't be the case your social
security number has nothing to do with
your like
cases for wine uh because that's a
system actually explicitly random
uh yet you know people are easily
manipulable and
you know the difference in sort of
valuations is like huge you know if you
have a loan happen to have a low social
security number or the last digit
low then you know you pay and you are
willing to pay um
11.73 if it's high uh you're willing to
pay like three times or even more
um as much so the huge difference is um
i'm sure that people are pretty easily
uh manipulable now notice that this is
those
questions that are asked here are sort
of somewhat unusual
um sort of items this is not asking like
how much are you willing to pay for food
at the food truck or like whatever like
stuff that you do every day um or like
you know for a pizza
because you know there people kind of
know already how much they're paying
anyway and if i
just ask you something else that's
different from the market price people
probably
would not want to to to be paying like
30 dollars for
uh even if their social security number
tends to be quite
high now um arielia and i'll
go further with this in some sense they
have sort of more radical
deviations um so they elicit people's
willingness to accept then
this is how much they have to be paid
to endure an unpleasant sound for a
different
length of time now why did they pick
like an unpleasant sound
[Music]
in part because they could provide
people like a sample of it
in part because people don't have any
experience with that it's
completely unclear how much you you're
supposed to be willing to pay to
uh or willing to accept for listening to
a sound um so there's no price or market
price for
it and people sort of had to sort of in
some ways rely on their own preferences
for that
and then you know it's very easy to
change the quantity you can do like 10
seconds 30 seconds 50 seconds it's very
easy to sort of manipulate
that now what is the procedure
subjects were listening um to of a 30
second sample of the noise
then they were as asks or answer
answering whether they hypothetically
would be willing to listen to the noise
for another 30 seconds for accents
and then they were asked their
willingness to accept for
10 30 and 60 seconds afterwards
notice that number two is only a
hypothetical question
and is essentially entirely irrelevant
for number three
so this is supposed to say number three
not number one um so
number two here is like completely
irrelevant this is
should really have no effect whatsoever
in affecting your willingness to accept
for
the 10 30 and 60 seconds again this is
just a hypothetical question that is
really um does not matter and that's not
going to be
implemented at all now and then the
experimental variation here
is that x was varied across um subjects
now why would x matter or what's the
what's going on here what's the
experiment trying to do
so people are very unsure about what
their evaluation is
so now what they do is essentially they
use um the
the x the amount that's offered as like
an anchor
um the same way as in like usually in
market when you go to like a store
and look at like how much do certain
things cost
and you don't know the quality of the
underlying items often people sort of
try to infer
quality or lack of quality from like the
price
and you know if you sort of say you know
if i'm telling you i'm gonna pay you
like hundred dollars for this it must be
really really painful so people try to
sort of infer in some ways
something from that now notice that this
is like explicitly hypothetical
and so on and and really it shouldn't
matter if people were sure about like
i just played with the sound so you
shouldn't be able to tell me how much
you like it or dislike it
so this should really be irrelevant but
people seem to sort of essentially just
not really know
what's appropriate or how much they're
willing to accept or not to do that
and x essentially sort of then anchoring
people okay so now
we get this like somewhat messy graphs
can somebody explain to me what this
graph
uh shows like what what do we what do we
find
so these are our one not sort of like a
certain subject and then there's like um
uh 10 seconds 30 seconds and 60 seconds
here
so people are always for each of these
lines on average at least
um willingness to accept goes up in the
way you expect in a sense that like you
know for more time people are going
asking
for more that's very reasonable right so
like 30 seconds presumably of worse than
10 seconds and 60 seconds or worse than
10 seconds but um the levels seem to be
completely arbitrary essentially giving
people
like a high anchor increases the levels
by a lot for each
each duration and giving people a low
anchor
decreases their willingness to pay at
least a little bit compared to no anchor
and surely compared to the high angle
that is to say and this is sort of where
this term comes from coherent
arbitrariness which is
uh essentially people seem to be
coherent in the sense of like once you
fix a certain level
uh based on that level if you ask them
like okay you tell me about like 10
seconds and i ask you about 30 seconds
about 60 seconds
this demand curve or supply curve you
want um looks pretty reasonable
but the actual level to start with is
completely arbitrary um
uh uh because you know i can essentially
manipulate you
by quite a bit look at the differences
in magnitudes
this is like 50 versus 30 that's almost
like twice as much depending on just
like this irrelevant
um anchor and there's sort of different
rounds in that you can sort of do this
one way or the other this is like
essentially increasing or decreasing
like starting at 10 seconds versus and
then going up
people's willingness to uh um to accept
goes up the longer it is
or if you start with 60 seconds let's go
down essentially people's willingness to
accept goes down the shorter death
so the direction is very much coherent
the direction of
essentially this sort of the the change
in terms of relative to duration is very
much coherent
the level seems very much um arbitrary
and so this is essentially whether the
title of the the
paper comes from arbitrarian is
essentially people's willingness to
accept uh dependence strongly on on x
for x equals 50 the willingness to
accept is like about 59
cents on average um for x equals 10
it's only um 40 cents but it's also
coherent
and very sensible ways the willingness
to accept so highly uh
sensitive to the duration in the very
much in the expected direction
longer it's always perceived to be more
painful okay so how do we think about
this well
so one um preferences can be influenced
by relevant queues
um uh for instance by an arbitrary
initial question or the social security
number or whatever that's being elicited
to start with
but once people have stated um a
preference
related preferences like you know
essentially uh surrounding preferences
are consistent in the sense of like if
you think you know i'm listening to the
sound is painful
asking you to listen to it twice as long
will be
more painful and therefore i have to pay
you more to do that
compared to like what you said in the
first place
any questions or is that is that clear
okay so now there's some concerns about
like
x might be um viewed as a hint from the
experiment as how bad the sound is
but you know like people just listen to
the sound for 30 seconds to start with
like i gave you the sound for 30 seconds
i told you exactly what it is
so in some sense um that seems like uh
not really a concern anyway but there's
also the variant of this experiment
where x was generated by the last two
digits of this
subject's um social security number uh
and explicitly so and still there was a
correlation between essentially x and
subjects willingness to accept which
really shouldn't be
um in any other uh in the absence of
such anchoring of
effects now stakes too low i told you
about like 30 cents and 50 cents maybe
people just don't care and so on
but there's also another experiment with
like 10 fold stakes and they got
essentially the same
results now so
uh uh so this evidence now is very much
consistent with the idea that subjects
are searching
for their preferences they don't quite
know their true willingness to accept
for the sound and this is essentially
arbitrary
but they know their willingness to
accept uh should relate to each other
in a coherent way and in fact wants to
fix sort of the level in some ways
they are in fact coherent or like
essentially uh uh
they sort of making sense uh they're
internally consistent with that once you
fix
a certain level now um
this is now getting back to like tom
sawyer now
the paper goes so this essentially is
sort of saying like your level of
willingness to accept for certain good
that and
that's unpleasant is malleable
essentially i can manipulate you
to um ask for like a lower higher price
depending on some irrelevant question
that i ask you for a given thing that is
perceived to be unpleasant
similarly i can manipulate you to pay
more or less
for a certain good that's perceived to
be a good something that you want
right so like the stuff on the social
security number that i showed you
previously
going back these are all kind of things
presumably there's some use for these
things you know belgian chocolates are
are supposed to be delicious rare wine
even if you don't like wine you can sell
it to somebody else or something
these are all things that are you know
you were worth they seem to be worth
willing to
to to pay for something and now
essentially
um given that you're willing to pay
something or some positive amount for it
i can manipulate now or the
experimenters in this
case can manipulate people uh uh
into higher lower willingness to pay and
so that's true for positive
for negative things now what's amazing
about the tom sawyer's story
however isn't the the the uh
it's ain't that work it's sort of like
that's the expression he sort of says um
towards the end uh the amazing part here
is that not only
is tom sawyer able to manipulate his
friend's
willingness to accept the willingness to
pay in one direction or the other
uh to sort of increase or decrease it
but he's even able to
flip it from something that he hates
doing that's essentially something that
you really do not want to do
or essentially one has to pay somebody
to do it but instead
his friend is willing to pay tom sawyer
for being able to do it right the friend
now instead of like having the friend to
pay for it you can say i have to pay you
ten dollars to do it
the friend is very happy to say uh tom
i'm gonna pay you
some amounts or i think he gives him
some apples or some candy or whatever
um so that he can actually do it himself
so essentially what the manipulation
here does is not only changing the
level for something that's good or bad
but it's flipping a sign
from like willingness to accept to
willingness to pay which is even more
radical
um deviation you might sort of think we
know what's good for us and what's bad
for us
but it seems to me that what tom sawyer
is doing is essentially manipulating
sort of the social perception
of the the item or the activity and that
sort of flips essentially the sign
of of the item so um
then our early now does um that in a
very sort of a beautiful experiment in
class and i
i always have wanted to sort of
replicate this but i i i'm not sure i
i should so what he does is uh at the
time this is with mba's
where he um did a port pre-reading from
walt whitman's leaves of grass
and there he has an experiment where
half of the class is asked
hypothetically
again hypothetically whether they'd be
willing to pay ten dollars to listen to
i really recite poetry for 10 minutes
like okay in class some of you um
uh are able to listen to this um but or
it could be like
i think it's outside of class because
otherwise there's some compounds and
are you willing to pay ten dollars for
for attending this like poetry reading
and i think actually aurelia is a very
good sort of story reader so it might
actually be fun to listen to it but so
you know they ask like hypothetically
again
are you willing to pay ten dollars for
it the other half then i ask
hypothetically are they willing to
accept ten dollars to listen to i really
recite the poetry for ten minutes that's
to say
it sounds like it's pretty painful to
listen to our reality
so he's gonna pay you ten dollars to do
it and you know are you willing to
to to do that notice that that here is
only hypothetical these are all
hypothetical choices that will not be
implemented so these hypothetical
questions should really have no effect
whatsoever on what's asked afterwards
because afterwards people are in fact
indicating their monetary evaluations
for one
three or six minutes of poetry reading
now you can already guess what's
happening here is here the first
condition is essentially asking for
people's willingness to pay that's
essentially selling the item is like a
good that's something that you really
want and you
it's sort of essentially encouraging
people to say well
you should be willing to to to pay
something for it even as much as like
ten dollars for
um uh ten minutes and that will
intensely encourage people
since they don't quite know listening to
your listening to your professors like
doing
some weird poetry could be really great
or could be really bad they don't quite
know but here essentially they're
manipulated into paying for it
while here they're manipulated into like
uh uh
being paid for it or asking for money um
uh to be paid for it
so now um what they then get is um uh
uh uh their willingness to pay and their
willingness to pay conditions when the
first condition here
where they are given that the
hypothetical ten dollars
for 10 minutes here the willingness to
pay
goes up and is positive and here it's
negative
and goes down so what we see essentially
is that
not only is it the case that when you
when you make it essential when you ask
people
uh uh how much are they willing to pay
people are in fact afterwards willing to
pay for it
and notice that everybody could have
just said zero if they didn't want to
pay
but in addition um uh once you sort of
fix the willingness to pay
the demand curve is very much like um
uh sensible in a sense once you're
willing to pay some amount for one
minute
you're going to be willing to pay more
uh money for like more minutes
essentially once we define this good to
be a good for you or like this item or
this activity to be like a good thing
for you
people say more must be better and sort
of are willing to pay more for more
minutes on the other hand once
um uh the uh item is um determined as
like a bad in the sense of like this is
really a bad activity
listening to your professor um uh
reciting poetry is like really awful
and you have to be paid for that then
they sort of say well one minute is bad
but like six minutes surely it's really
bad and you have to pay me a lot more
for six minutes
than for um one minute and that's
essentially saying
subjects don't know whether this reading
is good or bad
and but they do know essentially either
way more requires um
more money that's essentially exactly
the korean return is
where essentially the the level or even
like the sign
is really unclear but once the sign is
sort of fixed people behave and pretty
reasonable
um ways i actually don't remember i
should look it up but
it's really in the paper whether it's
possible um
in this condition to actually have
negative so the clean experiment would
surely
always ask you a whole range where like
you
you can always say um between say minus
6 or minus 10
and plus 10 and i'll tell me you were
willing to accept versus willingness to
pay so if it's positive it's willingness
to pay if it's negative it's willingness
to accept i think that's
what so surely that's how the experiment
should have been done
i would like to think and hope that's
also how it was actually done
i don't remember i read this quite a
while ago um but it's really in the
paper so i don't know if anybody
remembers but i think that
it's exactly right in some sense the
experiment is very much sort of
manipulating people in the way of saying
like well
uh so the the prompt here really gets
you into like okay you're supposed to
pay for this
now it's kind of a little bit of a weird
thing to say i'm willing to accept
you know professor says um you know uh
are you willing to pay ten dollars for
it
and then you say well how much are you
willing to pay for like you know six
minutes
and then you say well you have to pay me
like five dollars it's been a weird
thing to
say and the other way around so it's
very much sort of like i think
uh set up to sort of generate the
effects that they're looking for
i think the underlying so i think the
underlying essence and there's some
other experiments which are so
some somewhat similar results the
underlying essence is right that
for particularly for unknown goods
people's preferences are very much
malleable and people just don't know um
what they are
and there's also some other things for
example if you think about for example
social activities where maybe your
friends like them or they don't like
them
and people are very much like this is
exactly the tom sawyer example
where people are very much sort of um
malleable and you can
you can vastly shape what people want
versus
not uh in many cases and for example one
example would be like
there's some very nice work by their
boosting and co-authors
that looks at um education and sort of
do
do do students want to study versus not
and you want to like be a nerd versus
not in class
and so depending very much like on your
environment as a kid when you when you
grow up
uh if all of your friends are sort of
essentially not working hard and sort of
like want to be cool and sort of do not
want to study
and it's not a cool thing in your
environment to study um people might
just not want
that but on the other end if you have
like you know five
uh nerd friends who are all working
really hard or like if you're running
around at mit studying is a cool thing
and everybody sort of is working hard
and that becomes suddenly like a very
much like a desirable
activity so i think more generally while
this is a bit of a contrived experiment
surely people's preferences are very
much malleable
through their uh uh social environments
and what they think others
um um think and how to perceive it
and that can be better and shaped by um
uh so
manipulate manipulated in certain ways
and potentially affect it
that could be a very much like a policy
angle if you wanted to change people's
behavior profoundly without
um spending much money in fact um
let me i think that's mostly what i have
to say let me let me summarize and then
tell you about uh next week for
for for a second so we asked sort of the
question whether people have stable
preferences and it seems to be that
people don't have clear preferences for
goods and experiences
and sort of construct their preferences
on this spot now
um they're influenced by environmental
cues that
in a way that doesn't necessarily
reflect the true utility from the good
or
experience and that's very much also
what companies are doing in science and
sometimes you know
some items are made really really
expensive like
like why is this thing expensive and
somehow companies are able to
create some fads or some way of making
things desirable by just making them
expenses and making people want them uh
in that way
that very much relies on the fact that
people are in fact sort of malleable
and you can sort of introspect and think
about like what things in the world do
you generally and make you generally
happy what things do you really like
and what things are sort of more things
that like well other people like them
and you kind of like get sort of
manipulated or you get sort of like
tricked into
uh doing that in some sense i will talk
about this next week a little bit about
happiness
it's important to sort of try and figure
it out and try to sort of not perhaps be
as much influenced
by others and rather figuring out what
what you generally and truly um
like so there's some nice series of
experiments that sort of demonstrate
this coherent arbitrariness
um when very sort of like clean um
variation and somewhat contrived um uh
context so you might wonder then like
does it matter in the real world
well you know it's it's perhaps less
important than settings for people have
experienced again like if i had done the
same experiments with like pizza
um you know you know how much you're
willing to pay for pizza you know the
market price and you know also uh
and so on and so they are probably your
willingness to pay and your preferences
are very much like um
uh set but in some other cases and
particularly like new environments and
when sort of
new um when sort of preferences are
shaped
for example think about maybe back when
you first started at mit um
uh sort of seeing lots of other students
when norms are shaped
people's preferences are very much
malleable and can be influenced
profoundly now um
uh there's not so much like actual field
evidence in high stakes settings that
are sort of of this clean
nature having said that the examples for
example environmental
sorry educational choices it is perhaps
like the most compelling one because
that's really a high stake setting that
matters a lot
but people's preferences or their
choices are very much
malleable that's all i have to say for
on coherent retirements
um so um next time monday
we're going to talk about poverty um
please read the paper by
uh mani rao and then on wednesday may i
talk about happiness and mental health
now um i i promised you like a a
a guest lecturer and so you know i was
thinking about what's what's a good
thing to do and so
you may have heard about this at uc
berkeley they had essentially llamas
come to
to um campus to make students happy and
distress them in some ways
now of course i can can't bring any any
uh real
llamas but what i found and you may have
seen this on the on the daily show
there's this thing called go to meeting
where you can essentially get like a
um a goat or a llama um to come to your
meeting for um 10 minutes
um i did off i did ask for like a um
a llama to arrive but there's apparently
a chance that it might be a goat or a
cow
so um we'll have essentially a visitor
at the the end of the lecture
i think i asked for like 2 20 um or
between 2 20 and 2 30
um um in which we'll have a guest
lecture that will hopefully
uh either tell us about happiness or
maybe make uh some of you or at least
myself um
happy uh that's all i have for
for for today i'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have